seit anfang des monats ist nobelpreis
zeit in der weltweiten wissenschafts und
forschungsfeld gibt keine größere ehrung
als eben diesen preis was die
diesjährigen nobelpreise mit einem
studienabbrecher oder dem jetlag beim
reisen zu tun haben jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen er
soll an all diejenigen gehen zitat die
der menschheit den größten nutzen
gebracht haben
so hat es mal der stifter alfred nobel
selbst gesagt und zu dieser riesen
großen ehre kommt auch noch ein
preisgeld von knapp einer million euro
nobelpreis physik einstein hatte recht
der nobelpreis für sie geht 2017 gleich
an drei us physiker die auf den spuren
von albert einstein wandeln sie haben
jeweils mit ihren experimenten und mit
ihrer grundlagenforschung zum ersten mal
den nachweis von gravitationswellen
erbracht rainer weiss kipp von und barry
bärisch haben tatsächlich einsteins
formel werk bestätigt und ihr wisst alle
die messe und von gravitationswellen ist
nicht nur für die physik welt eine
sensation und auf diesen moment hatten
weitaus mehr als 1000 forscherinnen und
forscher hingearbeitet besonders
spannend ist dabei die geschichte von
rainer weiss der tatsächlich selbst
diesen einen unfassbar wichtigen
augenblick verpasst hat am 14 september
vor zwei jahren um fünf uhr 51
amerikanische art zeit lager erstens
noch im bett und war zweitens im urlaub
weit weg von seinen beiden kilometer
langen detektoren die plötzlich erzählt
hatten erst dachte er nur das sei ein
fehlalarm ein pseudo signal von seinem
forschungsteam um zu testen ob er
schläft nie ob die dakar auswertung
ausgearbeitet doch dann war klar dass
das system nach einem update für solch
einen fehlalarm noch gar nicht bereit
war und das war der große moment der von
jetzt auf gleich alles veränderte nach
jahrzehntelanger suche hatten sich
gravitationswellen messen lassen
ausgelöst durch den zusammenstoß von
zwei schwarzen löchern und wie immer in
der wissenschaft ist solch eine
entdeckung noch deutlich mehr wert wenn
sie wiederholt werden kann und
tatsächlich auf folgende messungen
bestätigten den nachhall solcher
kollisionen bei dass dafür der
nobelpreis fällig war ja eigentlich
noch eine formsache wenn man die
kindheit von einer weiß kennt dann hätte
man damit aber absolut nicht gerechnet
1932 wurde in berlin geboren seine
familie floh dann vor den
nationalsozialisten in deutschland erst
nach prag dann nach new york er bastelte
fiel vor allem gern im bereich
elektrotechnik doch das studium am
renommierten langweilte ihn schnell ja
warum nicht und so wechselte er in die
physik aber auch das brachte er nicht zu
ende denn er verliebte sich in eine
pianistin und sein herz für den weg nach
chicago verrückt komplett gaga hat er
später mal dazu gesagt denn am ende war
sie weg und das studium auch er ging
dann als labortechniker zum mrt zurück
und arbeitete sich dort zum professor
hoch zitat wir haben nicht groß über
gravitationswellen nachgedacht die
technik war faszinierend wir hatten
solchen spaß dabei sie zum funktionieren
zu bringen
ein bisschen wie kinder in einem großen
sandkasten nobelpreis chemie
schockgefrostet das leben als kinofilm
salmonellen sind immer mal wieder in den
schlagzeilen bakterien die durch
lebensmittel übertragen werden und bei
menschen durchfall auslösen können also
deshalb hühner und händlern flächen gut
waschen und ordentlich durch braten oder
backen ja und auch jetzt bin ich etwas
vom thema abgekommen sind sie im
wahrsten sinne des wortes noch einmal
besonders groß herausgekommen wenn die
erfinder der coro mikroskopie haben
jetzt den nobelpreis bekommen das ist
eine technik die die kleinsten
strukturen von leben und ihre atomaren
detail sichtbar macht eben zb ein
salmonellen bakterium das eine
körperzelle infiziert oder aber andere
zellen viren oder moleküle einzelne
eiweiße die nicht einmal unter einem
elektronenmikroskop zu erkennen wären
wenn seine strahlung würde sie zerstören
voll cool also büro ist dagegen dass
kühe elektronenmikroskop die objekte
werden sehr schnell auf minus 180 grad
celsius heruntergekühlt schockgefrostet
quasi und verschiedene zustände
momentaufnahmen alles mal eines moleküls
sehen so sichtbar und zwar ganz ohne
farbstoffe tatsächlich eine absolut
revolutionäre technik zeigt sie
forschungsteams doch beispielsweise
schnappschüsse davon wie gerade ein
stück erbgut kopiert wird oder eiweiße
ein stückchen herausschneiden ganz
großes kino also und die schauspieler
sind mikroben denn die methode erlaubt
innere von molekülstrukturen zuschauen
und solche großen momentaufnahmen
zusammenzufügen und das auch noch in 3d
diese technik nach vorne gebracht haben
die moschee joachim frank und richard
henderson und genau sie haben dafür
jetzt den nobelpreis in chemie gewonnen
der schweizer hat die moschee zum
beispiel hatte in den 80er jahren eine
methode entwickelt durch die proben aus
lebenden material eingefroren werden
können ohne dass sie dabei zerstört
werden nobelpreis medizin deswegen sind
wir abends müde das leben auf der erde
ist der rotation unseres planeten
angepasst so ähnlich heißt es in der
pressemitteilung des nobelpreiskomitees
für die erforschung der sogenannten
inneren uhr haben in diesem jahr drei
us-forscher dem medizin nobelpreis
gewonnen
wie wichtig die innere uhr ist merken
wir spätestens wenn sie aus dem takt
kommt zum beispiel bei einer reise durch
verschiedene zeitzonen oder bei
schichtarbeit die umgebung und die
innere uhr passen dann nicht mehr
zusammen das ergebnis ein fürchterlicher
jetlag ist die innere uhr dauerhaft aus
dem rhythmus plan kann dies tatsächlich
krank machen das risiko für verschiedene
krankheiten steigt die in ruhe sorgt
also tatsächlich für unser überleben sie
steuert hormone körpertemperatur und
natürlich unser schlaf der verdienst der
drei wissenschaftler sind die
entdeckungen wie menschen tiere und
pflanzen ihren rhythmus so anpassen dass
er mit dem rhythmus der erde also tag
und nacht zusammen passt so die
nobelpreis jury ihre forschung fand zum
großen teil in den 70er und 80er jahren
stadt ist also schon ein bisschen her
und zwar an der fruchtfliege sie
identifizierten gene die die innere uhr
kontrollieren eingehen dass sie
entdeckten nannten sie püriert weshalb
84 gelang es ihnen es zu isolieren und
damit gingen dann die jagd auf die
verschiedenen grundlagen und
funktionsweisen der inneren uhr
überhaupt erst so richtig los später
entdeckten sie ein protein per das
nachts ansteigt und tagsüber abnimmt
also genau wie der 24-stündige tag nacht
rhythmus und es folgten noch weitere
entdeckung einer reihe von proteinen die
für die steuerung der inneren uhr
zuständig sind sie alle bilden in der
gesamtheit einen eigenen zyklus und zwar
dadurch dass manche hammond und manche
aktivierend wirken morgens also werden
alle physiologischen prozesse gestartet
die uns aktiv machen abends
sie das gegenteil und das großartige
also noch einmal auf den punkt zu
bringen
die innere uhr produzieren selbst einen
rhythmus sagt dem körper auf was er sich
vorbereiten muss und beeinflusst hat 60
komplexe physiologische vorgänge wie
blutdruck schlafmuster oder die
ausschüttung von hormonen
ansonsten gibt es übrigens auch noch den
nicht so richtigen wirtschaftsnobelpreis
der aber eben nicht auf den stifter
alfred nobel zurückgeht den literatur
nobelpreis und natürlich den
friedensnobelpreis die aber hier bei
pixum glaube ich etwas dem rahmen
sprengen würde nobelpreise gibt es also
für die bahnbrechenden erkenntnisse und
über die wichtigsten ereignisse wie zum
beispiel die gravitationswellen die
bericht darüber berichten wir hierbei
klicks um täglich wenn ihr also kein
video verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
her ein abo ops auge und vergesst nicht
den auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit dem video zum thema
gravitationswellen dass wir sogar ein
paar tage vor der verkündung der
entdeckung online gestellt haben
da hatten wir glaube ich eine ganz guten
riecher da gab es also da gibt es in
diesem video alle infos zum thema also
unbedingt draufklicken viel spaß dabei
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran